take a look at this map it shows the
change in coronavirus cases over the
past two months
you can see cases are rising and as the
weather gets colder and people head back
indoors
experts say it could get worse as we get
through the fall and into the winter
with the holiday season going we've got
to do something
different experts warn that many
buildings like restaurants
schools and homes are not equipped with
a ventilation and filtration systems
needed to reduce the spread of covet 19.
so by now people are really familiar
with masking
hand washing distancing but fewer people
are aware
that ventilation and filtration really
matter
it's now clear that the coronavirus
travels through the air which is why
indoor gatherings can be so deadly
the virus can accumulate in aerosols
tiny droplets that gather in the air as
we breathe and talk
that virus is never naked in the air is
what we say
it's always floating in respiratory
droplets that are much bigger
indoors those particles can add up
increasing the risk of transmission
and one way to mitigate that is to pump
in fresh air with a ventilation system
we have to think about the thermal
conditions like humidity and temperature
but also just how much
outdoor air is moving in for me the
priority is to increase the air exchange
rate
the air exchange rate determines how
many times an hour
fresh air circulates through a building
there's not an exact recommended rate
but experts say that 3
to 6 exchanges per hour is ideal but
good flow of fresh air is only one part
of preventing the indoor spread of the
coronavirus
the other is filters and experts
recommend using one
called hepa this type of pleated
mechanical filter is made from
fiberglass
foam or cotton it can remove more than
99
of airborne particles including those
carrying viruses like the coronavirus
this is the same type of filter used in
hospitals and airplanes
but there has been some confusion over
whether or not hepa filters
can effectively capture airborne
coronavirus
that's because these filters are rated
for particles that are 0.3 microns in
size
larger than the coronavirus people
assume that they don't catch
anything smaller but that's just not
true filters are rated for the particle
size they perform
worst at and that's 0.3 microns as you
get to bigger particles
and even smaller particles the hepa
filter
will capture closer to 100 percent
because the coronavirus tends to travel
in droplets that are larger than 0.3
microns
hepa filters can capture almost all of
them the virus also travels in droplets
that are smaller
and hepa filters can capture those too
filters work
not by straining out things that are
larger than the holes in them
but they actually work by trapping
particles in the air as the air flows
around the different fibers in the
filter
when very small aerosols bump into gas
particles they move at a random pattern
that is called brownian motion kind of
like a drunk person
stumbling around in the dark and because
of that random motion
they can crash into the fibers the
harder it is for particles carrying
viruses to pass through a filter
the lower the chance of viral
transmission but the problem is that not
every building has a system that can
handle them
when you have a air system moving air
through the building
and then it runs through a filter you
can imagine that a higher efficiency
filter
that's more tightly woven is going to be
harder to push air through
very few systems can push air through a
hepa filter
unless it's designed that way because
hepa is the most efficient filter we
have
that is why experts recommend that
schools businesses and homes
use a different type of lower efficiency
filter called merv
if you can get up to something called
mirv 13
that's able to remove 80 percent or more
of
viruses that might be in the air this is
important
because this type of filter can be
installed in standard ventilation
systems like what you might have in your
home
still there are plenty of buildings that
aren't able to adapt this type of filter
either
many people are starting to realize for
the first time that their buildings
can't respond
their systems are not dynamic they're
not resilient they can't increase
capacity
older and underfunded schools face some
of the biggest challenges
according to the us government
accountability office 41 percent of
districts
need to update or replace their
ventilation system in at least half of
their schools
which adds up to about 36 000 schools
nationwide
the washington dc public school system
spent 24 million dollars on upgrades
to handle higher efficiency filters in
preparation for the return of students
and teachers
and it's not just pricey for schools
some restaurants will need to spend over
thirty thousand dollars to upgrade their
systems
in addition to operating costs you pay
more for energy to bring in more outdoor
air and condition it and also
work harder your system will work harder
to push air through a higher efficiency
filter the air pumped into buildings
also needs to be cooled or heated
which adds to energy bills even though
not every building can afford to make
these adjustments
experts say there are other solutions
for older buildings with outdated
systems
opening windows is a good cheap option
but in the winter
this isn't always possible and some
buildings have windows that are sealed
shut
if you can't hit the targets consider
supplemental air cleaning through the
use of a portable air cleaner with the
hepa filter
now if you size these correctly for the
room for
restaurant a school classroom a bedroom
at home
you can get four or five or six air
changes per hour
of clean air and it can be cost
effective
that's what the dc public school system
did in addition to upgrading their
ventilation systems
the bottom line we know that the
coronavirus can spread through the air
and we know how to reduce the risk of
transmission the biggest hurdle will be
the cost of putting the science into
action
you